Welcome back.
I keep rushing to try to get
under the wire for these
problems, but let me explain
it properly.
So what we did is, we said
that a new student joins.
And the average after he joins
is equal to the median.
And what we did is we figured
out, what's the average and
the median before the
student joins.
Well, the average before the
student joined was 13/12, and
the median before the student
joined was 1.
If the new student has 1 or 0--
and we established that
the only way to bring this
average down is for the new
student to have less than
the average number
of siblings, right?
That's the only way we can
go from 1 1/12 to 1.
And I'll tell you right now that
he's actually going to
have a 1/13 impact, right,
if he's 1 away.
So actually I can tell you right
now he has one sibling,
but I'll show it to you
mathematically if you don't
have that intuition
on averages.
But the important thing to
realize is that he's either
going to have 0 or 1 sibling.
He's going to have to have less
than 1 1/12 siblings, so
it's either 0 or 1 in order
to bring the average down.
And regardless of whether he has
0 or 1 sibling, the median
won't change.
If he has one sibling, then
we're just going to have
another one here and then
this'll become the median.
If he has 0 siblings, then
that's going to be a 0 there,
but that's still going
to be a median of 1.
The median is not
going to change.
So what we have to do is figure
out how many siblings
does he have to have for the new
average to be exactly 1?
So we can go back to
this calculation.
Let's take the average, but now
let's take it with him.
So this was our previous average
where we said well,
there's three students with 0
siblings, six students with 1,
et cetera, et cetera.
But now we're going to add
this new student in.
There's one student with
x siblings, right?
And instead of 12 in the
denominator, we have 13.
Because we now have 13
students, right?
So what happens?
You essentially have 13,
so this becomes x plus
6 plus 4 plus 3.
This becomes 13 plus
x, and then the
denominator is equal to 13.
And actually I was wrong before,
he's actually going to
have to have 0, my intuition
was a little bit off.
Because look, this is the new
average, 13 plus x over 13.
The new average is going to be
13 plus x over 13, right?
13 plus x over 13.
And what does that new average
have to equal?
It has to equal 1.
Because that's the new median.
Or the old median, because we
said the mean doesn't change.
So how can 13 plus x
over 13 equal 1?
Well, if you can't eyeball that,
you can just say 13 plus
x, multiply both sides by
13, is equal to 13.
And then subtract 13 from
both sides and you get
x is equal to 0.
So that new student
has 0 siblings.
I know that was a little bit
convoluted, so let me just
tell you what I did again.
I said what is the
current median?
And I just listed out all of the
number of siblings, and I
took the middle number,
and that was 1.
Then I said well, what is
the current average?
And the current average
was 1 1/12.
And this might confuse
you a little bit.
You could just say, well this is
the same thing as 0 plus 0
plus 0 plus 1 plus 1 plus
1 plus 1 plus 1
plus 1 and so forth.
Instead I said that's three
students with 0, six students
with 1 sibling, two students
with 2 siblings, and so forth.
And I figured out that the
current average-- and I
divided by 12-- was 1 1/12.
So I said well, no matter how
many siblings the next student
has-- and actually, it didn't
even matter, even if you had
more or less, one of the middle
numbers still would
have been the 1.
So the median will not change
regardless of where the new
student falls into the mix.
So we said, how many siblings
does that student need to have
for the average to come
down back to 1?
And then I just added x to my
previous average and I divided
by 13 instead because we now
have an extra student.
This was a 13 too.
And we got this equation: 13
plus x over 13 has to equal my
new average, which is 1.
And then I solved for
x, which is 0.
So the new student
had 0 siblings.
Next problem.
And the really fast way of doing
this-- not to harp on
this problem too much, and I
should have done this from the
beginning-- is to figure out
that the median is 1, then
figure out that it doesn't
matter how many siblings the
student has, the median's
still going to be 1.
You can insert a number anywhere
in this list and the
median would have still been
1 because there's so many
students with one sibling.
And then you just have to figure
out well, how many
siblings does the student
have to have for the
average to become 1?
That's probably the most
convoluted explanation I've
given, but let me just
hope it helps you.
OK, problem number 9.
If 2 times x minus 3 is equal to
8, what does x minus 3 over
x plus 3 equal?
What does that equal?
Well, let's just solve for x.
So we get x minus 3 is equal
to-- I'm just going to divide
both sides by 2, so 8 divided
by 2 is 4, right?
2 divided by 2 is 1, so
x minus 3 equals 4,
x is equal to 7.
So you go here.
What's x minus 3?
Well it's 7 minus
3, which is 4.
We also figured out that x
minus 3 was 4 up here.
And then what's x plus 3?
That's 7 plus 3, so that's 10.
4/10, we can reduce that to 2/5,
dividing the numerator
and the denominator by 2.
So that's our answer,
2/5 or 0.4.
Problem 10.
When twice a number-- so
whenever I start writing it,
let's say x is the number.
So they say when twice an
number-- so when 2 times x,
that's twice a number--
is decreased by 3.
So, twice a number is
decreased by 3,
the result is 253.
What is the number?
Well, while reading
it, I set it up.
So now we just have to solve.
So we add 3 to both sides.
2x is equal to 256, right?
I added 3 to both sides.
x, divide both sides by
2. x is equal to 128.
And we are done.
Next problem.
Problem 10.
OK, this says Outdoor Sneaker
Company's July production.
So we have white, black,
and then total.
And then they have high-tops,
low-tops, and then total.
I don't know if people even
wear high-tops anymore.
I used to.
I guess for basketball.
OK, high-tops, low-tops,
and total.
I'm very not plugged-in.
High-tops, low-tops,
and then total.
And what numbers do they
have in the box?
So there are 3,600 here, 1,500
here, 5,500, and then 10,000.
So even before reading this
question, I could tell you
they're just going to want us
to fill in this diagram.
10,000 here.
Outdoor Sneaker Company
manufactures only white
sneakers and black sneakers,
both of which are available as
either high-tops or low-tops.
On the basis of the information
in the table
above, how many black sneakers
did Outdoor Sneaker Company
manufacture in July?
So how many black sneakers-- so
they didn't differentiate
between the high-tops or
low-tops-- so they want to
know, how many total
black sneakers.
So that is black total.
So we need to figure
out this square.
Total black.
So let's see what we
can figure out.
I'll do my figuring out
in this magenta.
So if low-tops-- I need a total
of 5,500 low-tops--
1,500 are black, how
many are white?
Well, it's going to
be 4,000, right?
I just took 5,500 minus 1,500.
4,000.
Similarly, if I made a total of
10,000 sneakers and 5,500
are low-tops, how many of
them are high-tops?
Well, it's going to be 10,000
minus 5,500, so this is 4,500.
And out of the high-tops, if
3,600 are white and I made a
total of 4,500, how many
black are there?
Well, 4,500 total minus the
white ones, that's what?
That's 900.
And so if we want to figure out
the total black, we now
know how many high-top blacks
there are and how many low-top
black sneakers there are,
so we just add.
So 900 plus 1,500 is 2,400.
So I actually wasted both of our
times figuring this out,
so I could have saved a few
seconds I didn't do that.
But I was just mindlessly
chugging along.
Anyway, I'll see you
in the next video.